this april 19 million new cars were sold
in america
the highest level since 2005.
but these weren't just any old cars
today's
chevy silverados and ram 1500s
are not quite the same as those sold a
year or even a few months ago
something very strange is happening
across the industry
features packages even certain parts
have suddenly disappeared from recently
manufactured vehicles
an exceptionally observant buyer of a 21
silverado
for example might notice their truck
getting about one less mile per gallon
than was advertised
earlier this year on the same model
recent peugeot
308 hatchback owners meanwhile may be
surprised to find the digital
speedometer shown on tv
replaced with an old-fashioned analog
version
and the dashboard display on the renault
arcana mysteriously got
a little bit smaller it's as if they're
playing
a game what tiny things can they change
without anyone noticing
the actual explanation is a global
shortage of semiconductors
the chips that power virtually every
electronic device
from rice cookers to xboxes earlier this
year
auto manufacturers found themselves in
an awkward position
the average car is made up of about 30
000 individual parts
yet they were missing one worth perhaps
only four or five dollars
one hundredth of a percent of the final
selling price
it didn't matter without one single
component
everything had to wait at first factory
simply stopped producing and
workers went home ford honda
volkswagen audi and gm all shut down at
least a few of their production lines
audi furloughed 10 000 workers and
volkswagen predicts it will sell
100 000 fewer cars as a direct result
the total damage to the industry could
be upwards of 60 billion dollars
despite ordinarily spending only about 5
percent of its gdp on semiconductors
eventually though many brands resigned
to cutting back features
realizing the problem is here to stay
it's not just
cars sony doesn't expect to meet demand
for its ps5
until next year nintendo can't make
enough switches
and even deep pocketed apple usually
immune to such disruptions
has been affected according to goldman
sachs
semiconductors touch 169 different
industries
and the worst case scenario would be a
one percent reduction in u.s gdp
given how strong the incentives are to
alleviate the shortage
what on earth could cause such a costly
disaster sponsored by hover
get 10 off the domain you need to turn
your side project
personal brand or startup into a reality
early last year demand for cars around
the world
plummeted at the same time sales of home
electronics
skyrocketed routers monitors webcams
keyboards ipads and so on
car companies cancelled their
semiconductor orders
consumer electronics brands ordered
extra and to the extent the two
overlap production lines shifted to
producing for the latter
automobile sales however jumped back
much faster than expected
almost as fast as they had fallen in
march already by september of last year
demand for cars was near normal 2019
levels
not used to such wild swings and demand
when americans got used to their usual
habit of buying trucks the size of small
european
countries car manufacturers rush to
order more parts
the problem is that semiconductor and
rust
are practically antonyms there's nothing
fast about producing billions of
transistors on a single chip
or maintaining conditions 100 000 times
more sterile than a hospital operating
room
when you hear semiconductors have
extraordinarily long lead times
think not days or even weeks but rather
months many many months a
single chip takes no fewer than 14 and
as many as 20 weeks
just to manufacture after that you can
expect an additional six weeks for
assembly testing and packaging
this mind you assumes the requisite
machines are sitting around
ready to start the moment an order is
received and it doesn't include delivery
time
ignoring these two giant caveats each
chip will take
three to six and a half months from
start to finish longer than the entire
dip in car sales last year
but if it were that simple supply would
have caught up with demand
months ago instead some analysts don't
expect the current shortage to end until
later this year
or even next year something else
is happening here the semiconductor
supply chain isn't just slow
it also involves many different parties
steps which would be separated only by
conveyor belts or departments
in other industries are so complex for
semiconductors as to justify
entirely different highly specialized
companies
and while efficient specialization can
also cause
problems imagine for instance last
september when toyota saw its car
start to fly off the lot it would have
immediately adjusted its sales forecast
accordingly if sales the previous month
were
18 million it would have extrapolated a
trendline
and added some cushion ordering let's
say 20 million
but remember toyota's order doesn't just
go directly to a factory
instead it might go to a company like
panasonic which might be responsible for
delivering the car's navigation unit
panasonic on the other hand will see an
order of 20 million units
extrapolate and add some cushion maybe
ordering 21 million
it likewise may order from another
intermediary
who again will extrapolate and add slack
by the time an actual manufacturer or
fab
receives an order it may bear little
resemblance to the original
each step of the process involves an
independent profit maximizing firm
making the most logical decision given
its limited information
in aggregate however demand gets more
and more
distorted under normal conditions this
effect is known
and manageable but when orders come
flooding in all at once
as they did in september manufacturers
are very
easily overwhelmed and because demand
shot up everywhere at once every company
was effectively competing for the same
limited supply each one trying both to
minimize the risk of
under ordering and maximize its priority
in line
inflated its order for manufacturers
the difficulty is not so much solving
the shortage
with lead time so long there's really
nothing that can be done
except build more factories which takes
years
their real task is to project confidence
if they can credibly convince buyers of
their capacity
buyers will stop inflating orders and at
least
some of the shortage will naturally
resolve
it's fundamentally no different from
toilet paper
masks or diapers if even one person
fears a shortage
they'll start hoarding supplies forcing
everyone
including the most rational to play
along
shipping prices are at recent highs and
chinese companies may be hoarding
supplies for fear of u.s
sanctions but no one truly knows how
much
is simply panic buying in reality
the shortage may not be much of a
shortage at all
what if there was a shortage though
supply may not be severely constrained
now but if this is what merely believing
it to be
looks like what would it actually
the very nature of semiconductors all
but guaranteed the dominance of a small
number of companies opening a new
factory easily costs upwards of 10
billion dollars
and as much as twice that for the most
cutting edge but because of how fast the
underlying technology changes
it will very likely only remain useful
for five or so years
that means burning through a million
dollars every five
hours there's absolutely no room for
mistakes or downtime
factories run 24 7 365 days a year with
no exceptions
with capital costs this high it's simply
not
possible for new companies to dip their
toes in the market
over time the number of competitors has
dwindled
from 25 in 2002 to just three by 2016.
the winner in each major chip technology
revolution
reinvests its earnings back ensuring
they dominate even harder
in the next with just a handful of
competitors
the industry is among the most
consolidated in the world
more so than airlines biotechnology or
soft drinks
while not strictly speaking a monopoly
taiwan semiconductor manufacturing
company is the clear winner
in the contract foundry market which
produce on-demand for companies like
apple and toyota
that's a lot of very important eggs in
one basket
especially given that over 90 percent of
tsmc
fabs are located in one politically
fraught country
taiwan when semiconductors are flowing
no one pays much attention to just how
amazing their existence
is but when they stop when a single ship
blocks the suez canal or when an oil
pipeline is held for ransom
the fragility of our modern world
quickly becomes apparent
and yet it's in part that very fragility
which makes it
in all but the weirdest of times so
dependable
tsmc needs taiwan taiwan
needs tsmc and at least for now
the world needs tsmc
what you and i need on the other hand is
an online presence that we
control one of the first things i did
when i started this channel was create a
website
and to do that you first need to reserve
a domain name
a.com or dot io or dot app which you can
do with hover
for in some cases as low as 2.99
a website is the only place on the
internet that you really truly
own on twitter or youtube we're just
users at the whim of algorithms even if
you don't need a website
hover can also help you set up your very
own email address
your name at whateveryouwant.com for
example
hover is upfront reliable and affordable
with only the best customer support
reserve your domain with hover
and make your idea come to life with 10
off using the link in the description